we get the shots
yes
um
this is our main showroom in the store
you can see a lot of our
employees up top there hey everybody how
are you
safe we are we are dc's oldest hardware
store we've been continuously operating
in this city since 1866.
uh we've moved around a few times we've
been in this building for
seven years now like my father was
telling you
this is actually our second presidential
visit but our first one in this building
so welcome uh we're excited to have you
here today
and uh i want to teach you to marry
athletes a little wild thing
she has a separate business in our
building what they do is
it's micro green and i'll turn it over
to mary
sure we moved here a few years ago and
we are an urban vertical farm located
right next door we grow salad greens
micro grains and edible flowers
beautiful salads we deliver them all
over the greater washington dc area
both to homes and we donate locally here
in in the neighborhood
now you've been engaged in the
neighborhood too you've responsibly
achieved
we do we sponsor a little league team we
also
um we run job fairs for special needs
programs to get their
students to help them find employment
we've actually hired three people
from the from that job program it's
called project search it's a partnership
between
a non-profit and the dc government and
they do a great job
training their students who are special
needs and be able to
work an environment like this and be
great contributors have you hired any of
those folks entire three
great yeah thank you mary participated
in our first jobs there
uh we were going to do another one but
obviously the
pandemic has halted our ability to do
that but when things go back to normal
we're going to continue to do those
jobs tell me what kind of uh
what what hit you the hardest on
a pandemic kit right so um
the biggest challenge is what we're
going to do with our staff you know
there are so many
uncertainties related to what the virus
actually did
the first thing that we did was we took
all of our at-risk employees
and we sent them home and we paid them
through that entire process that first
wave of ppp
loans um was very helpful to allow us to
do that
obviously that was that was not cost
effective but we felt like we had to do
that for our
for our employees you know and we're
still we're still struggling because we
did well our retail business has
actually
increased over the course of the
pandemic i think people know there's a
little bit of a hardware boom
a big portion of our business is
actually government sales
and commercial sales and for the first
four or five months i mean that was
completely gone and that honestly
usually is about 60 percent of our
our annual revenue one of the reasons
why i
changed the rule for 20 days make sure
only
employers that 20 or fewer employees
could
qualify for people and the reason for
that was
400 000 small businesses went out of
business
they got in line but they couldn't get
the help and
we found out that an awful lot of that
went to big
bigger businesses that in fact weren't
supposed to qualify for this
because they uh used to be a thing
called inspector general to see where
the money went
and the last administration fired the
inspector general so a lot of the money
went to people who
shouldn't have gotten help and didn't go
to folks who would
but you know with this new program
and we're going to continue this
only businesses with fewer than
20 folks could apply the last couple
weeks but now
we're going to keep the focus on it
because a lot of minority-owned
businesses
women-owned businesses are increased
significantly by 25
20 and 15 as well as uh
getting people who in fact weren't able
to get in line before
and it's hard to know how to get wine
and so i hope
this is going to continue to increase
because we're also
at a point where i think we're going to
begin to gain control of these fighters
yeah right and i we appreciate your
leadership on that one quick point i
want to make is that
i said we're the oldest hardware store
in dc i also say we're the greenest
hardware store in america we have two
urban farms actually
in our building we have mary who's in
the garage there and then we have
cultivate the city
uh which is an awesome route top garden
uh they exist on
our rooftop but you can't you're not
gonna be able to see it from
from here but if they want to give a
wave i see them yeah
and then we also we need you
all right
let's go you guys
[Music]
what's up